hi i'm beardy man
where were you with that and i'm son
scott jesus
this is
this chemistry honestly
i'm with beardy man who uh are you just
staring stoked i'm staring dead into
that camera
oh no i was like on an epic crash scene
that's finger point
i'm with beardy man uh who
makes noises i don't know how to
describe you i 10 years ago i'd call
your beatboxer but there's a lot more
equipment here these days ever since i
started it i've been more interested in
using technology to morph my voice into
whatever else i
want it to be
and so
now you're going to do that to my voice
oh yeah
get ready you're going to be a mega star
that's tom scott hello
i'm beardy man hello what's going
what kind of music do you like tom
my music tastes are really basic
like regardless of the genre if you put
pop in front of it i'm probably gonna be
okay so like just just basic as hell
what about if you put pop on the end of
it like synth pop yeah yeah that'll do
or post pop sure okay um pop on the
beginning that is that is just pop made
out of the pokemon pack themed shoe
my goal for this was like banger that's
that's what i'm going for do you know
about hyper pop okay well like charlie
xcx is part of the whole like pc music
yeah collective she makes bangers and
they're like hyper poppy infused
caroline policeke also makes yeah let's
let's aim for that
caroline police let's let's aim for put
two guys in a basement doing that yeah
okay yeah yeah i okay this is a good
musical steer all right difficult to
pull off
well let's let's let's do it let's let's
go for somewhere around now cause it'll
pop
your singing voice
is um no doubt sublime so let me just
see if bit of auto tune i'll just talk
oh okay right so i just need to give you
[Music]
nice
there you are man
yeah okay so yeah so we can totally we
can do hyper pop because it takes from
like kpop which is like
dazzling and intense
and it's just a lot and um
but there's this kind of like squeaky
clean like commercialism to it yes yeah
right let's do it okay okay um so right
i'm instinctively i was just going to
the mic yeah i'm not right now oh okay
okay right so let's say what we need can
you just like put it really close yep
give me like a like just say the letter
b is as hard as you can like like
but that's
harder harder than that like like bit
like
yeah okay
no that wasn't that's good
no that's a that's not happening let me
give it one more time take out the
fricatives yeah
that's a that's a [ __ ] kick john i tried
to keep the aspiration back okay so uh
okay now i need something with
a uh place over the fricative please sir
[Music]
that's great um and now could you give
me could you like give me some sort of
like bongo-like sound by just going like
oh
give me like linguistics terms i did
linguistics i'll give you i actually
didn't do linguistics
but i i can say cluck like a chicken and
that's all
um all right but i know what you're
looking for you're looking for a canvas
you did linguistics back the throat
explosion yeah yeah sure
[Music]
it's good i think i want to layer that
this is good
[Music]
i'll push that down
[Music]
that's magic i've got no other word for
it
[Music]
all right
now i can give me a tis
[Music]
yep and a few more just variate the
formants on it
[Music]
that's legit it's all right so
that's incredible don't laugh man this
is no joke that's you're going to be a
huge star you're going to be supporting
caroline polo check on tour
i've already dmed her on twitter it's
happening right listen
i don't have words i love it when i just
get to stand back and watch someone do
i just
i
i don't have words okay that's that's
amazing where we're going we don't need
words check it check it check it um
let's go
[Music]
i think we actually need can you give me
like another really savage
plosive
like a uh
give me a few varieties of plosive with
with his little uh israelites
as little aspirations possible yeah
and no no vocalization at all
oh that was good give me that again
right
i can use that that's not what i wanted
but okay
[Music]
all right now some peas p's and b so
unaspirated but like yes this might not
be something you've ever done before
i've got to try and be loud without
aspirating when you're doing like a kick
drum yeah um and you're beatboxing your
kick drum if there's any kind of fuzz or
fists or aspiration at all it ruins the
effect so it's more kind of tensing your
lips as much as it looks
it takes practice but
okay i think i got one huh
that's actually pretty good
[Music]
could you give me some
more
[Music]
wait how are you making that oh so you
know how that was done yeah so i've
called it zap on here um
this is a vst plug-in called tornado
and when you turn up the zap thing
it's turning up this thing that's like
some words i vaguely recycle it's like a
tempo synchronized low frequency
oscillator which is sweeping a resonant
filter
that's what that's doing
so it gives you the impression of a kind
of laser zap noise yeah but
all it's doing is applying effects to
the statistics that you put in but i've
also on the way in i was quantizing it
live with the tempo so it doesn't matter
what you do it's always going to be
dead locked in time
um
let's keep going great
right
we will need like a sort of hoover synth
what do you want what vowel do you want
interpolate through a bunch of different
vowels i can do that yeah it's a
standard standard sweep through like ipa
vowel chart i can do that absolutely
right we're gonna start with okay
[Music]
i love that so much i would listen to
that all day
so i can
it's all very forward can i can i try
something some that's more no that's
perfect okay i was gonna swing the back
there but nevermind
[Music]
so
[Music]
i was going to ask if you wanted
something else for the bass but you kind
of you kind of got it yeah
[Music]
right we need some lyrics
wow
we need some lyrics come on i'm amazed
i'm absolutely amazed you need the tom
scott sample you need the do you need
the trademark tom scott sample i'm here
at the government
with a serious look and
hand based gestures yeah left that
agenda a while ago the importance
um yeah no because
the old tom scott is gone now there is
hyper pop scott
this should be your new hyper scott this
is
going no that's getting very close to
great scot there let's get very close to
back to the future
well give us give us some lyrics guys
it's all very good i mean give us a
topic first yeah what what what do you
write a hyper pop song about quantum
entanglement quantum entanglement i'm
not a physicist bridge in leads
[Laughter]
um a gazebo
a gazebo yo do you know what actually
you know because like
i i like the idea of a gazebo because
hyper pop is all about like
you know taking pop tropes and you know
doing them to the point of absurdity and
there was like the umbrella song by
rihanna why not do one about a gazebo
like you're under my gazebo
shelter me from the range that kind of
stuff you know yeah only one person in
here is a good improviser and it ain't
me
okay well that's a start like yeah i'm
under your gazebo something like that
and you can just you can just like say
the words i'll like yeah i'll play the
melodies yep shout to me from the rain
what else what else oh that's good
that's good yeah yeah yeah we should be
right when it's raining i do you want to
take the notes
take something that takes some notes
[Music]
so far we've got shelter me from the
rain keep me in your shade
which actually doesn't sound like a
great
metaphor yes yeah it's kind of clumsy
but like i mean it's more like i think
the shade thing it's like the shades
what you don't want every time my brain
locks onto a thing
oh i could say that no we are three
conversations further down the line
actually that's a good lyric you know
three three conversations further down
the line yeah yeah it's good it's kind
of enigmatic not sure what it means
great stick it in if it makes you go
wait what then it's a good lyric yep
we've got we've got a first verse here
do you want to just should i just sing
some things and you just you just flip
around yeah yeah okay yeah yeah yeah so
[Music]
do i do i speak do i sing how do you
want it
i think uh put it really close to your
mouth instead of shout as loud as you
can and that will do it yeah okay yeah
yeah can you hear it
i mean it sounds really bad to me should
i try again it might sound better now
shout to me from the rain keep it in
your shade three conversations
further down the line
i hate everything about that i hate how
i sang that like i i can't
like i would be trying to hit a key but
i don't know what key i need to hit yeah
it's confused it's confusing what might
help is if you sing quieter but cup the
mic and hold it to your mouth so there's
just more volume okay yeah i'll give you
a bit of
try two one two okay that is
that is very weird and uncomfortable but
we'll go with it
keep talking one two one two one two one
two one two one two one two
oh okay that's
wow
uh i'll just keep talking that is
that's speech jamming me that's amazing
okay uh i guess i guess i'll sing some
things and you
you try that
[Music]
shout to me from
[Music]
keep me
so those are not the notes i sang
but it sounds
way nicer than what i sang
this that's that's beautiful
[Music]
shout to me
keep me
[Music]
[Music]
okay let me let me give you another
lyric
three
conversations further down the line
that's great
okay
this this is good so there's our chorus
yep shows me from the rain keep me on
your shade yeah
sorry shout out to me from the rain keep
you in your showers right so it's
further conversation something
something it's great something like that
yeah so that's stuff about conversation
this is good yeah something about like
uh talking across purposes and like oh
that's nice you know yeah yeah
i like that i like that in the in the
chat crossed the wires of my broken
umbrella
that'll do that's going in
write it down write it down i'll write
it down
i'm going to change that to crossing i'm
going to change it to present tense
because the rest of the song is as well
oh hell yeah all right we're nearly
there we're nearly there we need one
more thing so we've got uh let me in
your shelter crossing the wires lost
connections we need like a a fourth one
on there oh someone said imperfections
oh i like that like i don't care about
your imperfections or something like
that or
fixated on your imperfections
i'm going to take two words off there
feedback and imperfections and just put
a comma between them
beautiful that's poetry yep don't make
sense doesn't have to it mustn't
it mustn't
so feedback imperfections and now we
need a a
generic statement you're the existence
i've been looking for i don't know it's
a bit heavy oh no i like that oh i like
that it means it means nothing
we're on the last verse we're fine
uh you're the existence i've been
looking for that is the actually that's
amazing is that manifesting like an ai
coming to life we've got a specific
request here folks we need a thing that
fits into the words desires and
transmissions we just need a fourth item
for that that sounds better
signal
a bit too close to transmissions better
in your shade the the the heat
shielded from the
how about i sound better in your shade
what i sound better
i sound better in your shade
yeah yeah i'm good with that i'm good
with that okay go with it go with it all
right
[Music]
okay one more time one more time
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
connections
[Music]
you're the existence
[Music]
me
[Music]
keep me in your [ __ ]
[Music]
i
[Music]
keep me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Laughter]
plug the tour if you want to see me live
you can come on my tour where i will be
doing stuff just like this
nothing about me in this has been vital
actually this has been the most
beautiful synthesis of musical
inclinations
yeah
it's so cool
i think i think we've got an outro there
i think we're good